Does any of this noise sound familiar to you?
They don't have the constitutional rights
to block me, Hurricane Irma hitting Jacksonville,
Is it revenge?
to say get that son of a bi#%$ of the field,
such poor leadership ability, President Trump
will pay dearly calling him a...All this noise
you heard all of it none of it is going away,
not a single one of them is going away it's
just going to be a different story a month
from now, six months from now, 12 months from
now, 5 years from now.
By the way, on top of all this noise that
you heard, you're going to have noise about
who you marry, your faith, your career path,
whether you chose to become an entrepreneur,
whether you say I wanna make six figures all
of a sudden you start making 7 figures, they'll
say money is more important to you, your friends
will start talking behind your back.
If you're worth 100 hundred million dollars,
oh my gosh this guy this guy is so full of
it.
If you become a billionaire you know what
they'll say,they'll say he's disconnected
from the average life.
But whatever you ever do, there's gonna be
this noise, so one of the things I had to
learn, took me years to learn this things
was this, you have to understand that the
noise if you aspire to become bigger in life
the noise is gonna get louder and more people,
you gotta turn off all the noise, let them
keep speaking because they are just promoting
you.
Turn off all the noise and do what you need
to today to execute your game plan and then
eventually people will realize that the only
time noise will stop is when you die.It's
the only time, it ain't never stopping till
the day you die.